- There is a mental
health crisis
and the left is
only escalating it.
They are increasing this
mental health crisis
rather than addressing it.
Gender dysphoria
used to be something
that you went and got help for.
And now it's encouraged and
it's pushed on our youth.
You know what, what an
adult chooses to do, do it.
But when you are
confusing our children,
when you are sexualizing
our children,
that is where the
line has to be drawn.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, we
are in Washington DC,
and joining me today
is a US congresswoman
representing Colorado's
3rd district,
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Dave, it is so
great to be back
in the Rubin Report with you.
- We were supposed
to do this yesterday,
but apparently even
a congresswoman
doesn't have the power to stop
our endless aviation problems
that we are having in
America these days.
- Oh, no.
You know, Republicans
are in the majority,
so we have a little more power,
but I'm not as powerful
as Tony Gonzales
who can shut down entire
border security bills
just with the
power of his words.
No, I was stuck in
airports all day long.
I mean, if you're just
gonna count Eastern Time,
8:00 AM to midnight, and I
had two of my boys with me,
which some people would think
that that causes for more
stress, more of a headache,
but it was awesome.
I had my 15 year old
and my 10 year old,
and we walked the
airports together,
we snuggled on airplanes,
we went and ate good
food in the airport.
They wanted McDonald's,
I vetoed that
and said, "Listen, you get
McDonald's any time you want."
But it was really great just
spending the day with them
and a unique experience.
Got home.
We got home at 12:30.
I put my 10 year
old in the shower.
I said, "I have been with
you all day, you smell.
I made you shower before
we got on the airplane,
and I don't think
you used soap."
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
So we still didn't get to
bed till after 1:00 AM.
- Do you ever wanna do that
with some of the
Democrats you're debating?
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
- Yes.
- You smell.
I'm putting you in the shower.
- I don't think you used soap.
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
- The mom instincts
come out in me.
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
- You know, individual
responsibilities
is usually not their thing.
- Right.
- Do your kids and and
family come to DC often
or is this just like you
doing your thing here,
in and out, kind of thing?
- Yeah, so I'm pretty much
on my own for the most part.
But when their
schedule allows it,
they certainly come up here.
We've pulled them out of school
to have weeks up here before,
because I had been
traveling so much
and just missed the
heck out of them
and said, why don't
you come out here?
And they act like they own
DC when they come here.
They go throughout the
Capitol, the office buildings.
They know which
members of Congress
have dogs in their office.
And you know, they go and storm
their offices and hang out.
But this is spring break,
so I have two boys with me.
My oldest son is
expecting his son any day.
- Oh, right, right.
- So, yeah.
So he couldn't come to DC...
- The fact that you're...
- I know. (laughs)
- Wait, how old are you?
- I'm 36.
- You're gonna be a
36 year old grandma.
- Yes, yes.
I'm a Gigi, Dave, I'm a Gigi.
(both laughing)
- How does that feel?
- You know, I'm really excited.
So my mom, she was
18 when she had me.
I was 18 when I had
Tyler, and now he's 18.
And one of his first
comments to me was,
"Mom, it's hereditary."
- Yeah.
- I said, "Nice try.
It doesn't work that way."
But I'm really proud of him
and my grandson's mom
for being responsible
because they could have
taken a different route.
And both of them chose life.
And so it wasn't anything I
had to browbeat them with.
I very calmly had the
conversation when we found out.
Just let me know if you
think something else.
I just wanna have
a talk with you
if you decide to go a
different direction.
And both of them
were very excited
and wanted to move forward
and welcome this
life into the world.
- Was there any part of that
that challenged
any of your beliefs
before you did that
sit down with them
and just realizing, you know?
- Yeah, so I mean,
obviously I'm a Christian
and you know, there
are standards that
we like to uphold,
but none of us do it perfectly.
One of the biggest
things that I look to is,
'Him who knows to do right
and doesn't, it's sin.'
And I mean, there's things
all throughout the week
that I know is right to do,
and sometimes I don't do them.
And so we can nitpick
what the Bible says
is right and wrong,
but I think just having
that heart posture
of wanting to serve God
and do the right thing
is so important.
And I mean, would I have
chose a different path?
Of course.
But, this is where we're at
and we're all embracing it
and we're so happy.
- Wait, what do you mean
you would've chose
a different path?
- For Tyler, for my son.
- Oh.
- Yes, yes.
So I mean...
- Meaning at this age?
- At this age, exactly, yeah.
He wanted to go
to UTI in Florida.
He was going to graduate and
go to college in Florida.
And now, he's looking at
petroleum engineering classes,
courses at our
community college.
It's a great community
college in Rifle,
but I get to have him
home with me longer,
and I get to be Gigi.
So certainly there
are some beliefs
that you're like, wait,
this isn't exactly right
and exactly what
we have taught you,
but this is where we're at
and we're going to teach
you about redemption
and how to move forward.
So I'm happy that
he's close to me
and I get to instruct him now
on how to be a loving father
and how to raise a baby.
- Let's do a couple things
about Colorado specifically,
and then we'll get to
the rest of the country.
When I did my book tour
back in May, I did Denver,
I'd stop in Denver,
and I was shocked at the amount
of homeless people there.
Like you expect it in Seattle,
you expect it in San Francisco
and Portland, et cetera.
But I was shocked by what
was going on in Denver,
which is such a gorgeous city.
And the people are
great and all that.
So what is going on in Denver?
- Democrats.
So, I mean, really
that's what happened.
We had universal mail-in ballots
about 10 years ago go through,
and Democrats started taking
over every single election.
And unfortunately, it was when
we had our gubernatorial race
that elected
Governor Jared Polis.
And after that is when we
just saw this dramatic decline
in Colorado.
Our policies infringing
on Coloradan's rights
and then just the crime
increase, marijuana.
It's legal in
Colorado, obviously.
And I think that that did
bring in a different...
- So you connect that directly
because as a general
rule, I'm more libertarian
and I do believe in
legalizing this stuff,
and I'm not against people
doing what they want
with their lives,
but even seeing in New York
what's going on right now,
the whole city just smells
like weed, basically.
- Yes, yes.
You can't go outside in
Denver and not smell weed.
And it's pretty much
throughout most of the state,
especially in those urban areas.
But I think it just
brought with it,
that legalization
brought with it
a different population
and certainly a
transient population.
And the homelessness has
just skyrocketed in Denver.
When we were having all the
COVID lockdowns and everything,
I mean, we just had
a complete encampment
right there at the
Denver Capitol.
- Yeah, I mean, you guys
like literal tent
cities everywhere.
- Yes, tent cities.
- I was shocked.
- Yes, and they are everywhere.
And they're not doing
anything to remove them,
so they're enabling the problem
and it is only increasing.
- What do you think of,
well, I guess I
know what you think,
but so Polis it seems
to me that people say,
when I'm always like, "Oh,
there's no moderate Democrat."
People are like, "Well,
Polis is kind of,
he's not completely insane."
But it doesn't sound
like the policies
are that far from
what we think...
- No, the policies
are very extreme.
And I do like Governor Jared
Polis on a personal level.
I mean, we've had
some interactions
and he has been very kind to me,
but his policies do
not match that moderate
or libertarian mantra that
people have about him,
even hearing stories
of him serving
in the House of Representatives
is very different
than what I'm seeing
as him being our governor.
And maybe it's his
cabinet members
who are pushing these
extreme policies,
and he's kind of
going along with it.
There is a super majority,
the Democrats have a super
majority in Colorado,
and the state legislature
pushes extreme policies.
And unfortunately those
get signed into law,
whether that's gun control
laws or comprehensive sex-ed
or vaccine mandates
for our children
in order to go to school.
And so all of this
is so extreme,
and from the top down, it
affects everyone everywhere.
The lockdowns affected
our businesses.
So many were shut down, our
churches were shut down,
our schools were shut down.
People were masked up
and just lost so much.
We didn't have a
statewide vaccine mandate
for the COVID vaccine.
And maybe that's why
people look and say,
"Oh, look, he wasn't that bad."
But in that circumstance,
I kind of see it like
as an abused spouse,
like, oh, he doesn't beat
me all the time, you know?
- Right, right, right.
(both laughing)
- We have good days.
- Right, 'cause I'm
telling you, I mean,
his name is on that
very shortlist of like,
not insane democrats.
And I would love
to interview him
and discuss some of this stuff.
So we shall see.
- I think you should
interview him.
And like I said,
like he and I have had great
conversations together.
He came into my
Washington DC office
and we talked about water
and it was a very
productive conversation
that we had about water.
Colorado doesn't have a
lack of that resource.
We have an over
allocation problem.
And so he and I are trying
to work together to see
how we can store
more of that water.
It's a low hanging fruit.
And you just came
from California,
well, California takes
a lot of our water,
and it's really frustrating
when you see hundreds of
billions of gallons of water
being dumped into the ocean
rather than stored in California
after we sent that precious
resource down river.
- Do you sense that Colorado's
gonna just sort of have what,
although Colorado I
think is somewhat purple,
it's gonna have what
the blue states have,
which is that the big cities,
so mostly Denver, will
just go increasingly blue,
and the rural areas will
just go increasingly red,
and then we'll just have
that nonstop tension?
- Yes, so I do see
increasingly blue,
but our red areas, I do think
that those are
turning more purple.
I mean, look at my race,
I won by 546 votes.
Our oil and gas
industry is gone.
We've been regulated into
poverty in our communities.
The Colorado's 3rd district
no longer has that industry
like we did.
And those companies have left,
they've taken with them their
employees and their families,
and it has impacted
us dramatically.
And I have all of
the tourist towns,
most of the tourist
towns in my district.
I have Telluride, I have
Aspen, I have Glenwood Springs.
We just had redistricting,
but I used to have
Steamboat Springs.
And we have Wray,
but Californians are
moving into those areas
and they're able to afford it.
The taxes are
cheaper in Colorado
than they were in California.
So they're like, this is great.
But they're taking
their policies
from California and
bringing them to Colorado.
- So, are you seeing
that for sure,
'cause it's really interesting.
What I've noticed is the people
that are coming to Florida
and where I live in
the suburbs of Miami,
like it's all new
people, but they get it.
They really do get it.
Everyone, like you can feel it,
like, no, I'm here
to keep Florida free.
I wear my Florida hat, so all
the OGs know that I'm cool.
But do you sense that it's
a different type really
that's coming to Colorado?
- Absolutely.
- That does kind of
make sense in a way.
- Yes.
People are not coming
to Colorado for freedom,
they're coming to
Colorado for a lifestyle
that they're accustomed to
and even policies that they
have voted for in the past,
but they don't recognize
that they failed them
and that's why they're leaving.
So they think, oh, if we
try a new form of socialism,
this type hasn't been tried yet,
so we'll try it over
here in this state.
- Socialism with snow.
- Right.
Socialism with snow.
- Yeah.
- And so unfortunately it's
not the same as Florida.
Florida's doing amazing.
And I mean, I'm envious of
how great Florida is doing.
You have America's governor
and we are just getting
more and more blue,
more and more liberal and
these extreme policies,
red flag laws.
We were at the top of the
list to get red flag laws,
and now our state legislatures
wanting to increase those,
they're wanting to ban
any kind of firearm
with a detachable magazine.
I mean, first we start off
with high capacity
magazine bans in 2013,
and now it's, we
wanna ban all firearms
that have a detachable magazine.
It's just as extreme
as you can imagine.
And I'm doing
everything that I can
to bring awareness to it,
show people, hey,
your votes matter.
We have the government
that we deserve.
We have to be engaged,
we have to be involved
and then certainly
help to strengthen
Colorado's 3rd district,
so we're not 546 votes
away from an election.
- I was gonna say Colorado...
Was it 546 votes?
- Yes.
- How long did it take?
It was like a full...
- Oh, gosh.
- Was it like two weeks or?
- Oh no, it was
longer than that.
It was in December when
we had the final count.
I was the last Republicans
race to be called.
So we had won, it was
an automatic recount
and so we had to go
and cure ballots.
And so if a ballot was rejected
because of their signature,
we were able to contact that
voter and get it corrected.
We cured about 700 ballots
and then won by 546.
So that entire effort
to cure those ballots,
every single one
of them mattered.
- Man, those go the wrong way,
you could've ended
up in Florida.
- Could have. (laughs)
- Yes.
- All right.
On a less humorous
note for a moment,
so we're taping this on Tuesday.
Obviously there was this
shooting in Tennessee yesterday,
we're gonna post
this on Thursday.
So some of this may
move a little bit,
some of the information we find.
The basics of what I could see
was the way, it's just
how everything is framed
in this crazy media lens.
Like now it sounds like this
was a biological woman, girl
who I guess identified as a male
or at least used male pronouns.
This is gonna cause the anti-gun
people to go for the guns.
It's gonna cause the people
who are pissed
about the woke stuff
to go after the trans people.
Like is there any way to have
a conversation about this
in a sane way at this point?
- Can we just put personal
responsibility on people
and say this was a terrible
person who did a terrible thing.
I mean, I do think that
we have a mental crisis,
a mental health crisis
in the United States
that's growing and
really being encouraged.
But I don't want to go after
an entire group of people
for something that
one person did.
Just like the left goes
after all gun owners
when something
like this happens.
Look, I'm from Colorado.
We're at the epicenter
of these school shootings
and it's absolutely terrible.
But you don't disarm
law abiding citizens
because of one nut job who
did a horrible heinous act.
And so also looking
at Nashville,
I mean, who stopped
this crazed shooter?
A good guy with a gun.
And so, I mean this has to be
something that we focus on.
I was actually just in
a committee hearing,
and let me say, I was
in the airport yesterday
when this broke and my
boys and I prayed together,
just the families and
everyone affected.
And I know the left
goes after that,
"Oh, we don't want your
thoughts and prayers,"
and this and that,
but I mean, I believe in
prayer and that works.
And I know the power of
the wraparound presence
of the Holy Spirit
and how he can just comfort
and heal broken hearts.
And so, I mean, that's
something that we did together
when we heard about this.
But there's so much...
I was in the committee
hearing on the ATF rule
with the pistol brace,
and I actually got
completely sidetracked
because I wanted
to say something
that I had said in years
past and used to believe,
I wanted to start off and say,
we don't differ in our
hearts, we differ in data.
But I stopped
myself and said, no,
we do differ in our hearts
because I don't want
any child killed.
And they're talking about this
as the leading cause
of death for our youth,
is gun violence.
No, not even close.
Actually, it's
abortion, you know?
We're aborting nearly one...
- That's the new meme that
they're using constantly now.
- I haven't seen that one yet.
- Well, it's gun violence.
- Oh yes, yes.
But yeah, I mean, we're up to,
I mean, nearly a million a year
and that's never discussed.
And so we do differ
in our hearts
because every life is valuable.
This is why I'm so proud of
my son and his girlfriend
for choosing life.
Even if you look at
rural and urban areas,
the teen pregnancy rate
isn't much different.
But the teen abortion rate
is much higher in urban areas
than it is in rural areas
because we value life.
We care about that and do
have personal responsibility.
So we wanna look at data
and see what we can do
to protect life.
And I want to arm teachers,
I want to have secure schools.
There was an idea I proposed
in the last Congress
to take some of the unspent
COVID money and secure schools,
protect our children.
We protect Congress with
fences and miles of razor wire
and tens of thousands of
armed National Guards,
because walls work and
armed security works.
We secure our airports,
we secure our banks.
Why not our most precious
asset, our children?
- Let me ask you about
the arming teachers thing,
'cause there's part of me that's
not inherently against it.
But then when you
see how many teachers
are actually
left-wing activists?
- Yes.
- How many teachers
are actually teaching
this woke craziness?
How many teachers are
clearly not good at their job
or actually quite negligent
in their responsibilities?
What do you do about that?
Because it's not as if
you're just gonna hand
guns to people, train them,
and they're gonna be
ideologically lined up with you
in a way that's gonna make
any sort of sense.
- Correct.
Well, I don't think most
of those woke teachers
are going to be
volunteering to be armed.
There's certainly circumstances
that are always
beyond my imagination.
But in Colorado, we
actually have a law
that allows teachers
to be armed.
It's up to the school board.
If the school board says
teachers can be certified,
then they go through
the certification.
And we have an organization
Faster Colorado,
that trains teachers.
And it's a very extensive
tactical training course
that they're taught how to be
responsible with this firearm.
Most have had experience.
You have retired
military personnel,
retired law enforcement.
And I think that having
some presence there
able to defend the students
is a really good thing.
It doesn't have to
be every teacher,
it doesn't have to be
the majority of teachers,
but even knowing that
there is someone there
to stop an imminent threat,
I think that is a
large enough deterrent,
because even we're
hearing reports,
I don't know how true they are,
but we're hearing reports
that the shooter in Nashville,
whom I won't name,
nor give pronouns,
said this was a soft target.
Like this person knew
that this school was
not going to be able
to stop the shooting.
- So at what point though,
I know you don't
wanna blame groups
and I think that's important
and I literally didn't
tweet about it yesterday,
'cause I was just like,
I just don't want to add in
the midst of the craziness.
Everyone gets in on it for
clicks and all that stuff.
But at what point do you
think the Democrat rhetoric,
and this is what they do
to you guys all the time.
The Republicans are
always defending guns
and it's their fault.
So I don't wanna
do that same thing.
But at what point,
when you constantly tell
this group of people
that they're oppressed,
that there's a trans genocide,
all of this stuff that
is just patently untrue,
at what point do you have
to look at your colleagues
and be like, do you see
there is a problem here.
You actually are radicalizing
a certain set of people.
- No, I do think
that that's true.
And that is something
that we need to speak of.
Just this one
particular instance,
I don't want to blame
all of the people,
but yes, there is a
mental health crisis
and the Left is
only escalating it.
- Yeah.
- They are increasing
this mental health crisis
rather than addressing it.
Gender dysphoria
used to be something
that you went and got help for,
and now it's encouraged and
it's pushed on our youth.
You know what, what an
adult chooses to do, do it.
But when you are
confusing our children,
when you are sexualizing
our children,
that is where the
line has to be drawn.
When you are telling
elementary students,
three-year-olds, five-year-olds,
you could be a boy,
you could be a girl.
Well, they could be a mermaid.
I wanted to be a
mermaid when I was four.
You know, I lived in
the pool and you know...
- Decepticon.
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
So, I mean, this is a problem.
And it is radicalizing a group.
I saw a CNN article that says,
if you've ever tweeted
a meme of a black woman,
well then that's
digital black face.
This is the new,
'oppress me of the day.'
You know, oppress me please.
And when you're telling
someone you're not good enough,
you are oppressed, you
are the lesser person,
you are the lesser class,
well then that's going
to get inside of them
and cause depression and
more mental health crises.
So it is something
that I believe
that the left is
radicalizing and encouraging.
- So what do you do to reach
across the aisle on this?
'Cause I'm doing about
10 or 12 interviews
all with Republicans
when I'm here.
We reached out to Democrats,
not one responded,
and I spoke to Senator
Ron Johnson yesterday.
He basically said,
"Well, none of the
Democrats will talk to me."
I spoke to Crenshaw and he said,
"Well, kind of on the
DL they'll talk to him."
And some of them
aren't that crazy.
Gates gave me a similar
version to that.
Who are the not crazy ones?
Do they talk to you
and is there anything that
can be done with them?
I mean, if I'm too scary
of an interview for them,
it's like I'm not known for
the hard wall interview.
I try to listen to people.
- Yes, you do.
- But they won't sit here.
That's the thing.
- Yes, well, I mean,
that's the problem because
the Democrat party has
their marching orders.
We saw it during
the speakers race.
Everyone's yelling at
the Republicans saying,
"You have to get unified.
This looks crazy."
Well, we have
independent thought.
The Democrats were
told what to do
and they did exactly what
they were told to do.
- Right, even the
radicals, like AOC.
- Even the radicals, absolutely.
And even the Congress
before that they had,
they were forming a coup
to take down Nancy Pelosi
and they took the deal.
They say, "You know what,
my committee
assignment's good enough.
Thank you ma'am,"
and walked on.
And so much of this, they
don't want to engage.
We see it in debate.
They want to say
their side and leave.
They don't wanna hear
the opposing views.
A lot of times if I'm
debating on the house floor,
I'll go early.
I'll hear what the
Democrats have to say,
my colleagues have to
say, I'll stay later.
Sometimes I even ask
somebody for their time
so I could go up and respond.
- Does anyone else do that?
I feel like nobody
listens to the talks.
Like someone gets up there talk
and they're like,
nobody's there,
but it's on CSPAN
or we see the clips.
- It is very rare,
because you do have
your scheduled times
and our days are
really busy here,
so I understand it.
But usually you go in
for your two minutes,
that's what you have to speak.
Maybe it's five minutes
and then you get out
and you're onto
the next meeting.
And it's almost feels
like it's by design
to keep us so busy
that we can't engage
with our colleagues.
And back to the speakers race,
that was one of my
favorite parts about it.
Those four days, we were all
together on the house floor
debating, engaging
in conversations
with our colleagues.
I talked to Republicans I
had never spoke to before.
I talked to Democrats I
And it was a wonderful four days
of actually getting to know
and understand one another.
- Were you worried that, I mean,
ultimately you guys
got some concessions,
but were you worried as one
of the most outspoken people
sort of against McCarthy,
that you were gonna pay a price,
just personally
even if you got...
- Oh, absolutely.
But that wasn't going
to be what determined
what I was doing.
I couldn't say,
"Oh, I'm never going to
be re-elected again."
If that's my only thought
is my next election,
then I have no
business being here.
I need to do what
I believe is right.
That's what I was
sent here to do.
I convinced and promised, what,
hundreds of thousands of
people that I'm a leader,
that I'm strong, I'm principled.
I'm going to stand for them
and fight for them.
And so I wasn't going to sit
back and go along to get along
and say, "Oh, my
committee assignment,
oh, I don't want a primary,
I don't want leadership
spending money
against me in a race,"
or any kind of repercussions,
whatever you could think of.
I knew to do what was right.
And this was all about
these negotiations
that we had started in the
summer and in good faith.
And I'm glad that Speaker
McCarthy saw the merit
in what we were asking
for and gave them to us.
I want to use more of the
tools that we've received,
and some of them, it's
just not time for them yet,
like the Holman rule,
that'll come up more
in appropriations.
But I don't want to only
admire what we received.
I wanna put these tools to work.
- I'm interviewing him
later today at the Capitol.
Is there anything I can
push him on for you?
Anything you need
a little nudge on?
- I actually think...
- 'Cause I like the fact that
he seems like he's coming
alive with this stuff.
- He does.
- It really does seem
like it's happening.
- He really does.
I think Speaker McCarthy's
doing a really great job,
and I'm not just saying that.
He is very aggressive on this.
Even the January 6th
videos that he released,
that wasn't part
of the concessions,
that was a bonus.
You know, and so
this is amazing.
If there's anything that I
wanna be more aggressive on,
it's subpoenas.
And this isn't anything
against Chairman Comer
or Pat Fallon who's
a subcommittee chair,
and the subcommittee,
we had the ATF hearing.
We had an ATF hearing
without the ATF.
I want the ATF in and
they are coming in April,
but I want to start
issuing these subpoenas
and being very
aggressive with it.
The Democrats are.
- So, I'm glad
you mentioned that
because you were part
of the Twitter hearings
and there was a
great viral moment
where you basically were like,
"You guys did this to me.
Like you did it to me
and I'm a congresswoman."
- Yes.
- And this is what I've asked
everyone else who has sat here
over the last couple days,
what actually comes of
this stuff other than,
okay, we can expose some of it.
So you bring out a
Twitter executive.
He kind of did some bad stuff,
sorta sometimes did
some decent stuff.
But what about the
government side of it?
Like when are we gonna drag
or when are you guys gonna
drag out the government agents
who actually were
communicating with them
as opposed to the
Twitter guys who,
it's not that I have
sympathy for them,
but they're private employees
who were probably in over
their head and whatever?
- Yes, and so we did have
former FBI Agent Baker
that was in there.
- But he had been
appointed from Twitter
- But he was working
for Twitter, correct.
We do need to bring
in these people.
But we called those hearings,
Twitter file hearings part one.
So we are going to have more.
But unfortunately, Dave,
I do think that
these next two years
are two years of exposure.
And I want to expose
the federal employees
who are involved in
this more than anything.
And then hopefully, the
Inspectors Generals look at this
and there's some
sort of referral
that we can actually
get criminal referrals
for some of the things
that have been done.
But I don't know if we can do
that in this administration.
- So basically you need a
Republican administration
to actually do anything.
So the hope is you can get
people to know enough about it.
- Right.
- Temporarily.
- All the top guys are
Biden's guys right now.
So that is our biggest struggle.
So we have to build this case.
We have to expose
what's been hidden
from the American
people for years.
There has been no oversight in
the House of Representatives
and there still isn't much
oversight in the Senate.
The Democrats have
the gavel there,
and they aren't going to
bring in serious people
to have this oversight.
So it's our job to carry
the weight of the House
and the Senate and
make up for those years
where there was no
oversight conducted.
- Not to beat a dead horse,
but were there any
Democrats in that hearing
that were like, oh, actually,
even though I'm a Democrat
and they were mostly
going after Conservatives,
this is a violation of
the First Amendment.
Maybe even on the DL, did
anyone say anything to you?
- You know, if there
were, I didn't hear of it.
And so everything was
extreme, MAGA Republicans.
And you know, I did set the
record straight and said,
"Listen, we are not
extreme MAGA Republicans,
it is ultra MAGA."
(both laughing)
But we were exposing how
the federal government
worked with Twitter
to suppress the
Hunter-Biden laptop story.
They didn't wanna touch that.
Everything is January 6th.
And they're using
what they know works
because it did work for
them in the last election.
But now we're exposing what
happened during January 6th,
what happened with
the censorship,
the lockdowns,
the fraud, the waste abuse
with the COVID funds.
And Afghanistan,
other committees are
having hearings on that.
We had a soldier that had the
suicide bomber in his sights,
and he was not allowed to
neutralize that threat,
in his sights.
And now we have 13 of
our soldiers killed.
I mean, absolutely disgusting,
but we are exposing
what was going on,
and the American people
are gonna see it.
And I hope in the
next two to four years
we have actual accountability.
I don't want any show pony
hearings like Benghazi.
I want people to be
held accountable,
and so do the American people.
- Do you think, it's kind of
funny when Biden keeps saying,
the extreme MAGA Republicans
or ultra MAGA or whatever,
like he's sort of talking
about your wing of the thing
as if you guys are
completely running the show.
And the whole point is that
you guys were on the outside
and had to fight
for a lot of that.
But he's basically
trying to paint everybody
as if you and Matt and Gates
and a couple other people...
- Well, we will take it.
If they want us to run the show,
let's run it because we have
some really great ideas.
I mean, look at even the
debt ceiling proposal.
It was a House Freedom Caucus
that came out and
said, we have a plan.
We aren't going to default
on our nation's debt,
but we're gonna claw
back some of this stuff.
Some of the unspent
COVID funding,
the student loan program,
we're taking that back.
I mean, if you wanna just
do pennies on the dollar,
we're not building your
$500 million FBI building
that you need, that
you're brand new building.
And so there's a...
- Is that one of the
things they're going for,
the FBI needs a $500
million building?
- Yeah.
You know, really important.
Gosh.
So there are things
that we can...
- They really deserve it
after the last couple of years
- They've worked so hard.
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
It was really the
raid, they're like,
"Hey, we need a bonus after
this Mar-a-Lago raid."
So, we have a plan,
Joe Biden's plan it
increases taxes on everyone.
They are doing nothing
to reduce inflation,
to increase energy development.
Everything that they're
doing will increase inflation
and reduce energy.
We have 20 million Americans
that can't afford their
utility bills right now.
We have a wide open
southern border.
We want it secure.
We want the flow of
fentanyl to stop.
And so we have a plan,
and I told Joe Biden in our
press conference, I said,
"We're meeting
tonight on the Hill.
You wanna come here, put
down your ice cream, join us.
We'll have a conversation."
And...
- You know, it's funny.
The guy keeps coming
downstairs and says,
the only reason I'm
down here for ice cream.
And I'm starting to believe it.
Like, that's the only reason
he's coming downstairs.
Like, I like ice cream.
And everybody's like,
"Oh, there's the old man
who likes ice cream."
- Exactly.
Well, we hear about the
horrible tragedy in Nashville
and he says, "I hear there's
chocolate chip cookies."
- He literally did like a
five minute standup routine
about ice cream
when he came down.
I mean, nuts.
- Yes.
- All right, let me
ask you one more,
I know you hit the gym
before you got here.
- Yeah, I did.
- You got a long day of stuff.
You gotta get outta here.
One more for you.
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
So you talked about what's
gonna happen in two years,
hopefully.
Obviously, this thing seems to
be like going back and forth
between the Trump,
DeSantis thing.
I know you love Trump.
You obviously said some nice
things about DeSantis here.
I think you have a sense of
where I'm at on this thing.
What's your general take?
And actually, do you
think there is a way
which would be my preference,
that it doesn't have to
end up in destruction
of one or both?
That would be the best way,
but I just don't know
if it's possible.
- Correct.
At this point, I don't know
if it's possible either.
I think there's
room in this tent
for both President Trump
and Governor Ron DeSantis.
I would love for
this to not end ugly.
I have endorsed President Trump.
I do endorse President Trump.
I believe that he
will be our nominee.
Obviously, Governor
DeSantis has not announced
that he's running at this time.
But I mean, even the way the eft
is still going after
President Trump
with the DA in New York,
they do not want him to run
because they know
that he will win.
And I mean, think about it,
they're not going
after Nikki Haley.
She's a member of the club.
She's paid her dues.
They're not worried about her.
But they are going after
President Trump still.
They have not left this man
or his family alone at all.
And I think Governor
DeSantis has great potential
to be president of
the United States.
I just want him
to wait till 2028.
- Any final thoughts or
should we end on that?
That seemed pretty
clear. (laughs)
- I love President Trump,
and Governor DeSantis,
you just keep Florida
strong for a while.
- Well, the funny thing
is, for me, I'm like,
look, if Trump ends
up the president
and DeSantis stays governor,
I'll be freaking thrilled.
I'll be thrilled if
DeSantis is the president.
It's like, that's
why I just don't want
the mutually assured destruction
that seems like it's on the way.
- Yes.
- So we shall see.
- We shall see.
- Good luck for the
rest of the day.
I'll try to nudge
McCarthy for you.
- Thanks, yes.
Let's get some subpoenas.
We've issued tens so far,
let's make it hundreds.
(Congresswoman Lauren laughing)
Thanks Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.